i'm sorry what is your name cleopatra
cleopatra what a great name uh
cleopatra where'd you grow up were you
from originally
18 i'm sorry egypt
egypt really and you came to the united
states at what age
am i playing i'm sorry by playing
by playing at what age when i was like
eight years old
when you were eight mm-hmm then tell me
about your childhood you had both your
parents
i don't know them you don't know your
parents no
who raised you uh
i don't remember
you don't remember who raised you no did
you go to the foster system or
no so who did you live with when you
were
10 years old 6 years old with some
family
i guess but your mom and dad were out of
the picture
no you never you never knew your mom and
dad
no
and what kind of kid you went to high
school
um yes what kind of what kind of kid
were you in high school
uh
evil evil in what way
because i wasn't paying attention to the
to my classes i guess
that doesn't make you evil
so you weren't a good student you were
not a good student
no i think how far did you go in school
actually i was in the school to learn
english oh you just weren't you just
went to school to learn english
play high school then call the place
i'm sorry high school before the high
school
before high school did you go to high
school no you didn't
but i was kind of going to the high
school
and you ended up going out on your own
at what age
when did you start living on your own
very long time ago
how old were you 21 i guess
i had a small crystal man you heard what
small crystal man
sorry i smell christmas oh you smell
crystal meth
when did that start for you like two
years and
two years ago is that why you're down
here in skid row
yeah actually i came to look for with
estimate
it's not a crystal meth down here not
the same as in the place where i live
there's more over there than here where
do you live
radio hill gardens where is that
by dodger stadium okay a little bit
north of downtown
so the crystal meth is better over in
that neighborhood than here
yeah because in my home like a lot of
people have it done here
it's better quality
or there's more of it the people have
more
so i can get it more easy than here
because i
came here like two hours ago i didn't
get nothing
you're not looking hard enough i think
it's everywhere here
yeah but i have to pay for it in my hood
i can get it for free
oh you get it for free how do you get it
for free
because i have a lot of friends
how do you support yourself now
i have some friends who give me money
sometimes i'm sorry
my friends sometimes give me money what
for
don't know do you i mean
so you're transgender yeah
are you ever doing sexual favors for
money
no no you don't do that
are you homeless now are you that you
have an apartment i
i don't know if i i am homeless because
i have a place where i live
but i it's kind of homeless and not
being homeless
yeah you're not paying rent no but you
do have a roof over your head somehow
yeah and how old are you
21 uh huh
i awake into reality
i awaken to reality
you're you're awake into your reality in
what ways
i draw myself in something
and then i was just looking at it and
then i something just happened
and i was in the in the jointing
in a cockroach or was over my foot
like walking by a river that's why i
call myself your partner
that's why you call yourself cleopatra
because i awake into
reality like lupatra by a river
in a forest i suspect you're actually
from maybe mexico
huh are you from mexico originally or i
like to call myself that i am from egypt
i know but where are you actually from
guatemala
i thought you might be hispanic of some
sort
but you're a beautiful cleopatra i like
you i like to call myself but
you know when after i smoke bismuth i
start
listening to some voices
and i was being harassed by those boys
because they said that i was the
cleopatra movie that is trying to kill a
woman
for being in some place but that's not
me
being cleopatra means that how i wake
into reality by everywhere
that was for freedom i'm sorry i awaken
to reality by a river
and that was so beautiful i that was my
goal
by smoking christmas
what does crystal meth do for you uh
that really takes me into the trauma
i mean i like to go into the trauma
because i haven't studied psychology
before
and i like to see what happened you know
what what trauma did you go through i
guess a
house thing house
housing was there anything in your
childhood that was traumatic
um house because i had to leave my
country when i was so young
then i came up here
so you came from guatemala yeah but i
like to think that
the place that i came from was it
because it was a
big river in iowa
i you know i try to to think
so you do you do know your mom and dad
or you don't
those voices try to tell me that they
don't like me and i am like
okay cool there's none although in the
universe that they should love me
did you did your family not approve of
your wanting to be a woman
no they don't approve me for the house
thing
those voices
[Music]
and by being transgender they are cool
with it
they don't have any problem what is the
most difficult part of your life
the most difficult um was when i
awakened to reality and they told me
that i was you know that there's a place
named
rome wrong yes in italy
yeah but instead of going that place
they told me that i was in rome
down here and they were harassing me a
lot
that was the most difficult for me
those voices they really believe that i
am cleopatra i don't know why
but it goes for real but i feel like you
patra you know
you feel like cleopatra and i
do have like uh like
you know that there's a child in my mind
he's alive cleopatra have you ever felt
like you were loved
by your family or anyone else alone
what do you say have you ever been loved
yeah
by myself when i stopped looking for
approval into my
you know people yeah
i'm going to therapy next month and
my big request for therapy is going to
be
house because i have to accept the way i
live
i live in the forest by a river
mm-hmm yeah therapy would be a great
thing excuse me
therapy could be a great thing for you
yeah
and i want you to smoke crystal
naturally again because i want to go
into the trauma
and yeah when i smell crystal meth
it's very fast to go into very deep into
my unconscious
and what i do is that i question i go i
question my
my my thoughts like my negative
it's interesting yeah
[Music]
how often are you using crystal meth
every day
sometimes yeah and i wanted to crystal
meth again today
last night i dreamed because
i dreamed myself that i was in when we
in the you know tom what is the name
that
when we die
but there was a guy with me there yeah
there's a woman because i call myself
the building's sleeping beauty the same
because for me being cleopatra is the
same being sleeping beauty
and she said that she's the witch
and that she seems that she wants to
kill me
she sometimes is choking very harassing
things to me
but they are fighting the house
i am i am on the crystal met now
what emotions do you deal with cleopatra
pressure emotions yeah do you get angry
depressed
um anxious angry
[Music]
who are you angry at you who are you
angry at
um i guess that angriness
come because for the house actually
that's my big fight because your family
didn't
accept you no i didn't have problems
with it
it was the opposite i didn't accept my
family
i'm sorry i didn't accept my family i
guess
you didn't accept your family no who are
you angry at
uh for the housing
that was my biggest trauma i don't have
any more of that trauma
but i have to accept the way i live i
have to accept
all of those things that's why i want to
go into the drama today
today again and when i smoke crystal med
those voices come to to my to me and
they start harassing me
and you like that i like it because they
i can i can see what's the trauma
like now i feel that i don't have any
traumas
i have been working in myself like for
two years doing
inner work
but the most beautiful thing was when i
wake into reality
in a draw you know have you heard about
vitamin k
like what byron katie i'm sorry
buy it on katie i don't understand her
byron katie is a woman who and she had
awakened to reality the same way as i i
walk into reality by a cockroach
a car crashing was walking on my foot
and then i
felt that i was alive
okay what's the most important lesson
you've learned
in your life the most important lesson
i respect people's sexual likes i guess
[Music]
like i not like when people do crystal
med they can get very horny but instead
of
you know touching myself of you know
trying to have a sexual behavior
i start writing a lot about my negative
thoughts
[Music]
and i have been sober for like so many
days now
for two years
you've been clean for two years but
today's your day
huh but today is your day you're gonna
use again if i
yeah if i got you my whole day that i
get the hot wheels metal battery i'm
going to smoke again
all right cleopatra well thank you so
much for sharing your story
and i wish you the best of luck with uh
whatever you're doing
okay therapy sounds great though yeah
thank you very much be careful out there